if you tuned in to twitch last weekend
you may have seen something truly weird
oh my god he's biting me oh my body oh
jesus the german 985 doll house was
honestly one of the wildest things i've
ever seen broadcast on twitch a sort of
live the sims like experience where
viewers were able to vote on what
happened and help to manage germa's
physical and emotional needs
or
not i want to take a shower put me in
the shop i don't want to go to work i
want to go in the shower you know i
can't go in front of people like this i
can't do that i'm loves to stretch
i'm not do
i
not only was a stream incredibly weird
and entertaining but it was also
successful it had about 80 000 average
concurrent viewers on its final day and
peaked at over a hundred thousand but
even more than that this was a serious
production involving a big crew
and honestly it kind of pushed the
limits of what entertainment on twitch
can be so i wanted to take a look at how
this stream happened but also who the
hell is this germa guy and how did he
end up cheating on ludwig with death
itself
[Music]
listen i love that i get to talk about
weird [ __ ] like this but to maybe help
that continue consider liking the video
subscribing to the channel and ringing
the notification bell it's kind of like
you're the audience and you're deciding
what's gonna happen with the channel
okay so twitch is no stranger to live
content where viewers choose the outcome
twitch plays pokemon was at the time a
massive phenomenon on twitch but even
though it was entertaining it was
basically just viewers voting on button
presses the german 985 dollhouse which
took place on august 18th 20th and 21st
took the idea to a whole new level the
basic concept recreate the sims complete
with a big set for a house and starring
twitch streamer germa as the main
character
and that meant that viewers were able to
choose a lot of things what germa did
how he spent his money or even how he
acted towards other people this is a
game this is a this is a game
where you have to play by the rules of
the game essentially right you guys are
going to have a lot of things to be able
to do this is not a scenario where
somebody just like
tells me to go like zerk off into the
fridge for an hour so that's not how
this is gonna work
uh you'll have a lot of [ __ ] to do but
that's not one of them now obviously
we're talking about a big production
that needed a lot of staff to pull off
and according to germa between
sponsorships from twitch and coinbase he
basically just had enough money to pay
everybody and pull this thing off and
with the choices offered to viewers and
the various npcs including appearances
by ludwig and kit boga
the stream took some pretty weird turns
ah no no no no no no
it smells like [ __ ] in here
right
that's
that was the laugh track moment
maybe he had some
it's a little late towards the end
ludwig even took over the house
you can deal with it pretty simply deal
with a pretty straightforward it's
called get out get out of the house hey
how about you get out of my house no you
get out of my house oh is it your house
look at this paper not neatly nothing's
but not this one actually
that is a legal document and ludwig owns
the property and what the [ __ ] are you
talking about
so watching all this crazy [ __ ] happened
i had to ask myself
why do something so intricate and who
the hell is this germa guy if the name
sounds familiar you might recognize him
from the world of team fortress 2 and as
germa told tyler mcvicker of the valve
news network it was the game's rising
popularity that really helped him to
take off the uber update for tf2 was
really
where i started to see an uptick in
viewers
really doing those yeah doing those
weapon videos talking about new items
and
anytime a major major update tons of new
players were coming in tons of new
people were coming in but germa didn't
just make guide videos he was funny he
made in-jokes for his community and he
became really popular for the time at
least for team fortress 2 standards his
voice and appearance also bore a
striking resemblance to the game's scout
grass grows birds fly sun shines and
brother i hurt people oh they had that
i would have punched that medic right
this burned his mouth face and according
to vnn the scout character's canon name
jeremy is actually an homage to germa
germa what's it like knowing that valve
named the scout after you by the way i
can confirm that they did that
wait what
scout's name is jeremy and it's because
of you
wait that wasn't just a coincidence no
i know for a fact it's because of you
yeah holy [ __ ] that's the first person
i've ever heard that so germa did the
youtube thing for a while where he
uploaded gameplay videos guides and even
just meme videos like his shp series i
just found
a wild spade nest
on dust bowl and this is they pop up
from time to time but i've got to be
really careful here guys this is the
middle of mating season blush bees and
red spears are going to be mating
gotta be very very quiet here
[Music]
but when he branched out from tf2 his
content got even weirder like when he
held a live action fighting tournament
featuring some insanely bizarre fighters
it's a giant rat that's a giant rat
i'm not sure how i didn't see that
before i must be having vision problems
wait the giant rat is biting his leg
just gnawing at him and the christmas
tree
[Applause]
but then he eventually decided to swap
over to primarily live streaming and he
got even more experimental and surreal
some of it also involved voting like
part of his carnival stream where his
twitch chat tried to democratically aim
a tennis ball at a dunk tank target that
would dunk both germa and a laptop
you'll never dunk me you [ __ ]
scalia it's not gonna happen
not everything germa does is a massive
production though he also does low-key
streams just playing weird games and
regularly losing his [ __ ] uh quick quick
quick heaven
heaven you english heaven wake up wake
up wake up wake up wake up
you want me to stream snipe chuck e
cheese in fall guys on stream oh by the
way
that's roger rabbit slimer cubert and
carnage
the four horsemen of an apocalypse
shoot stomach
i shoot head
shoot head
shoot stomach
why did that take so long
and sometimes these weird streams were
intricately planned world building
exercises
like the time that germa invented a
pokemon ripoff card game called grotto
beasts that was apparently so bad it was
buried in the desert
then he dressed up like a child's idea
of what an archaeologist looks like and
unearthed them on stream whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa wait wait wait wait wait
a minute wait look at this one
look at this one this one this is
cut to my face quick quick quick quick
quick
quick
quick
quick
quick
quick quick quick quick quick quick quick
catch my face
a foil razzle plus whatever he does
germa makes it hilarious even if he's
just eating a whopper
i'll try it i'll try a bite and we'll
see
okay i'm gonna go for a
bite my god
it's so good
oh my god
but he's also been trying to make these
big events more elaborate which is how
he got the dollhouse an idea that
emerged over four years ago in
offline chat four and a half years ago
we made a couple of offhand comments
about being like a
in like a simulator
and like what if i was in like a
dollhouse and you guys could control me
and like funny things happened in quotes
i was like oh that sounds like a pretty
funny idea and then four years later we
decided to do it seeing this idea fully
realized must have been really cool for
him but i think it was even more
entertaining for the audience who went
out of their way to make sure that germa
had a really fun time what am i doing
what you i
oh mike
dude look over there don't look
look
don't look over here don't look over
here get back let it get out and get out
of the room
okay so jeremy's guest ludwig is of
course a man of taste
josh berry's voice
love it
i don't know what it is he he always
does these uh these narrations i'm just
i'm a simp that clip never gets old man
and i'm sure his appearance helped the
stream i mean he was hilarious and
seemed to be having a really good time
with it but the truth is that this
stream was an intricately planned piece
of media that required over two dozen
people and a huge set to pull off so
that got me thinking have we honestly
even scratched the surface of what
twitch as a medium is capable of listen
the basic streamer playing a game and
reading chat formula is awesome and if
you're watching this video there's a
strong chance that you understand that
too and of course there are streams on
twitch that are more akin to traditional
media programming like talk shows or
panel shows
but what we saw on twitch this past
weekend doesn't really have a real world
analog it's part sketch comedy part
role-playing game with a side of
professional wrestling and a big glass
of democratic participation to wash it
all down and it was hilarious it worked
germa added over 90 000 followers during
the weekly period that included
dollhouse and he had over 2 million
channel views during the same period and
that's the most exciting part for me
this stream broke new ground the last
stream on saturday ended the only way
that it could with the consent of the
audience delete the save file i would i
would appreciate it if they deleted the
save just delete the save we can get out
of this place they said no again why are
you keeping us in this prison why i'm
trying to release everybody but they
won't let us go oh yeah
[Applause]
for a so-called compact streamer who got
famous making funny tf2 videos this was
a hell of an achievement but he better
not rest on his laurels quite yet
because i personally can't wait to see
what this weirdo has in store for us
next
listen you get that jalapeno ranch dip
oh oh my god that's the goat that's a
goat a w dip for real it's jalapeno if
you haven't tried the jalapeno i don't
like ranch actually but like
it's it's so good like i
that's what ranch needs
you know
ranch needs a friend it needs a friend
named jalapeno and they can just chill
together you know and then you just eat
it the metaphors collapse but you get
what i'm saying